facing the right-hander native aldi 1-1
to 394 era
and chasing down he goes strike three
vasquez has to throw on to get him
and complete the k two away
three two on the way he smoked him in
97. nice start for nate of aldi
two punch-outs matt schumacher will make
the start here this afternoon
2-2 and he got him there's a good
splitter first strike out of the ball
game
first pitch swinging sends a fly ball to
right field back pedaling
with room reaching back t oscar
hernandez hauls it in and matt shoemaker
has a one two three bottom of the first
oh nice breaking ball to strike him out
three in a row for native aldi
lourdes gorilla lines the ball at a
right center field vertugo overruns the
ball and guriel because of that
will dive head first into second verdugo
just couldn't pick it up cleanly and
that'll be a base hit and an error
sure will be strike pitch to gritchick
and he buried him struck him out with
that breaking ball that's four k's for
nathan
mitch moreland up red sox have not had a
base runner yet there
mitch mooreland lofting that one to
center field backing up it's grit chick
he's turning around
that ball's gone up onto the tarpon
center field mitch moreland strikes
again
his fifth home run and the red sox grab
a one to nothing lead here in the second
half he hasn't gotten even 30 at bass
with his
fifth home run that target right in the
middle of his chest
that gets away he's got a hurry better
hurry up
and they get him in first
right down the middle to strike him out
looking one away
kevin bizio let off this game by flying
out to deep right center
a ball driven to deep right center and
biggio hits it out
fenway couldn't hold this one bradley
couldn't get this one and biggio's got
his fourth home run of the season
as the blue jays tie it yeah kevin hit
one
in that same area last night and
he's gonna rip this one that's gonna get
all the way to the warning track and
skip up against the monster and he's got
a lengthy single
jackie bradley a nice start to the third
inning boy that's got to feel good
drops down a bunt a little bit of a
problem with that and he's going to be
out at first base down to second jackie
bradley we'll see if the red sox want to
look at this
so they will look at it this play is
under review this big play here
that should be an error on the pitcher i
would think because he had a chance
oh he's safe he's safe
back to the hill he'll throw into the
outfield
jackie bradley rounding third he is in
the score zooey lin
hustles into third base and another
misfire another mistake
by toronto the red sox have a 2-1 lead
and there is the ground ball to third to
second one back to first
in time just what they were hoping to
get
he puts him away he's had that heater
but as you said the curveball has been
his best pitch tonight
to try to make up for some of the games
they've lost the oscar bangs one down
the left field line
then intend he retrieves it and it's a
double for hernandez
well taylor did a great job on his
breaking ball because it was a breaking
ball that was inside and he had to draw
his hands close to his body
he draws his hands in close to his body
so he can get the barrel on that ball
and he's able to keep it fair and that's
the
fourth double forte oscar runner at
third
two down ivaldi back into the wind up
and a swinging aligner into center field
for a base hit
and guerrero drives in hernandez with
the tying run
hits it toward the end of the bat but
he's so strong and gets enough of it to
drive it into center field
and cash in de oscar from third
and the three two and struck him out
that's number seven for nate of aldi but
it's a 2-2 game
took a little bit off and he strikes out
bogarts bogarts came in
strike three called he can didn't help
him there
swung on him missed he got him again
that's number eight for a ball
you would take it
tempting was down into the dirt and he
went
so he's got another one back-to-back
strikers he has nine yeah that curveball
is magic
and he gets it by him strikes out ben
and tendy number five on the afternoon
got him good splitter down back-to-back
strikeouts
two-two score bo buchet leading off the
sixth then he drills the ball to right
center field and gone
the shed with his second home run of the
season and the blue jays have taken the
lead
well we mentioned that blue jays hitters
there's guys in the lineup that have hit
home runs off of aldi that's the second
career home run bushette has against
nathan of aldi
devers launching one hits the ball deep
headed toward the triangle and that
ball's out of here
raffy devers with a blast
[Applause]
and let's see if that knocks him out of
his slump that's one way to do it and
this game is tied at three
oh did he ever need that
but no walks which is so refreshing
that's a tough play
denver's guns got him at first base
grit should cut down and he can run and
raphael devers with his best defensive
moment of the young season
how tough is that going to the line
charging as hard as you can and picking
it up with your bare hand
and getting that throw off the first
space i mean pick up the out what a play
mitch moreland with a home run in the
second inning one for three today
high fly ball that one's back there
back there wade went back he did it
mitch moreland with a walk-off home run
into the monster seats
with two down and the bottom of the
ninth inning and the red sox winning
five to three he did it he did it